- So I love that-
This was so smart because, as a super fan,
you also released a greatest hits, right?
With the documentary?
- Yeah.
- With Cheryl. So like
what, tell us about that.
- So there's obviously,
the catalog is filled
with songs that everybody knows.
And then there's some
songs that were featured
in the documentary.
And there then there's three new songs.
And what was kind of
interesting about the new songs,
well, first and foremost,
there's a cover of a Rolling Stone song.
It's called "Live with Me,"
which is featured in the documentary.
It's the first time I ever got to sing
with the Rolling Stones.
- Wow.
- And I was super nervous, but we recut it
and then I thought I'm just
gonna text Sir Mick Jagger.
Yes. I have his phone number. Oh my God.
- That's amazing.
- And asked him if he'd
play some harmonica on it.
And he's like, yeah. And so
I sent it and so he's on it.
- Wow.
- And then I don't ever put
my kids in social media.
I never have.
- Yeah.
- And they're actually featured
in the video called "Forever."
And I wrote it really for my
kids just cuz our kids now
are so stressed and they have
big things they live with.
I mean, we're in a war.
Are we gonna lose somebody
that we love to a pandemic?
I mean, there's all these
- And just growing up
- Not to mention just being
a teenager is kinda hard.
- Yeah.
- And social media.
And so I wrote a song called
"Forever" and they're featured
in that and they're just...
- I love that.
- Precious
- And one day he's gonna
play bass with you.
That's my favorite part
- One day he's gonna
play bass with me, yes.
- Ugh Like that would kill. I would cry.
If my kid said that to me.
- I just feel certain by
the time he gets to be
old enough to be in his
own band that being in his
mom's band is probably
not gonna be like...
- I think he's gonna be
rad and he can do both.
You can do both.
- Yeah. Maybe.
- Yeah. I'm just saying.
- He's probably gonna ask me though right
off the bat, like what he's gonna make.
- You know what I mean? What's the salary?
- But you know what
you've raised him right.
- That's right. That's right
- I know my worth mom.